a garage is a great man cave for dad
right especially when it serves burgers
so chad duffield is here to tell us
what's brewing at sicki's garage for
father's day and beyond and we're not
just celebrating father's day this month
with you guys right there's there's
something going on at sickies a
milestone yes looking around for 10
years we like to say cheers to 10 years
cheers to 10 years where's our drink you
bring us a cocktail well we're
celebrating today with some throwback
food items right these are some original
food items to our brand we were
originally in fargo north dakota okay
we're bringing the midwest to the west
here in las vegas right all right some
original throwback so so what does that
mean midwest cuisine what is that well
that's what's in front of us we've got
some potato salad balls right fried
potato salad ever had that in the west
coast no no
of course not right we've got this item
right here this is a tater tot hot dish
cheeseburger okay so combining tater
tots and cheeseburgers i am in heaven
okay and hot dish is like minnesota for
casserole right so that's what that is
that is a casserole
tater tot cheeseburger that's totally a
bedwest right yeah absolutely it sounds
so delicious too and jc was so jealous i
was doing this by the way because he
loves sicky's burgers and i just i
cannot wait to bite into one okay now
what about this one this looks like a
chili cheese dog on a burger yes it's
our chili cheese fried burger it's got
homemade chili which is excellent
cheddar cheese sour cream and french
fries and these are a fun item we've got
this is a funnel cake
fry right a little carnival for you
these are some of the different sauces
check that out we've got strawberry
raspberry chocolate caramel now is this
something popular in the midwest yes i
mean rental cake is popular around the
world but absolutely as french fries
though yeah what's a new thing with
doing but it's a fun fun thing to do for
the summer time and kind of identify
with our midwestern roots this is cool i
love that oh they're so good which what
sauce do you suggest i like the salted
caramel i think that's the one i think
you should try that
okay and while i do this let's talk
about the specials for father's day
father's day here it is i don't know if
you can see this wow every every dad
that comes in the building we're going
to get one of these too okay so you come
visit on father's day as a dad and we'll
give you one of these which is a return
trip back to the restaurant for a free
burger which is what everybody burger is
a great place to have family friends
watch a game we've got 35 tvs we've got
every sports package you can imagine
right we've got 50 burgers 50 brews 25
flavors of wings and boozy milkshakes so
if you're a dad uh-huh i think we're the
spa yeah what i love is you guys combine
so many things that we love into one
dish or one drink okay that's amazing
and now there's a there's several
locations right across the valley so
let's talk about that because wherever
you are across the country across the
country yeah so we have eight across the
country currently we're going to open
two more before the end of the year now
we're expanding beyond that as well
so yeah we've got locations across the
wild you can come check out so okay and
if people want to just walk in should
they should they call ahead or they're
walking in getting served
both you can call ahead we can
definitely put you down or you can just
come by and stop in at your leisure
we're there for you we're ready to take
care of yourself oh that's great now are
you dad i am a dad so what does it mean
for you on father's day would you have
any plans yet well of course with the
kids and the fam wanted to make sure
that i just give thanks and appreciation
for being in the position i meant to be
a dad right so it's a great
responsibility that i really enjoy and
someone spent some time doing this kind
of stuff with them so that that
tradition can live on so so do you teach
your kids how to cook absolutely oh so
they're flipping burgers too of course
it's a family experience
i think the best memories are spent over
food yes so let's create some great
memories come to sickies have these
things create some great memories and
celebrate father's day i love that now
the midwest menu though the special
midwest is going to last until july the
31st okay so you can come down until
that time and enjoy some of these items
i love it all right well thank you so
much that was fun thank you and now in
today's headlines entertainment